Thinking, can we prescribe Ivermectin? No, Ivermectin has to be a
prescription by a licensed practitioner and you're gonna have to find somebody that will
give you a
a
prescription to a compounding
pharibacy. So typically Ivermectin is going to be available in 3 milligram and 12 milligram doses
that
That's that's how they're made if you need a dose that's different than that
Then you have to go to a compounding pharibacy so that they will compound it in a dose of 30 milligrams or whatever.
Now, I do know that there's websites out there that allows you to
To just go on and order the Ivermectin
Lied and then they have a doctor that just calls you and does a brief little consultation with you and then they said you the Ivermectin
There's pros and cons so that the pro is obviously that you're able to get that without finding a local doctor that will work with you
If you don't have any local doctors that are alternative minded in your area
The condo that is that typically. It's fairly expensive. I do know also that it is possible to order Ivermectin
Over from overseas so you do have to look in some websites
From that I have had multiple people that have ordered Ivermectin. It all sorts of different dosages, you know, 12, 20, 30
Milligram dosages
For fairly cheap from overseas so that would be something to look into as well
Second part of this question is Ivermectin used for lymphoma Ivermectin can be beneficial for lymphoma
So lymphoma is one of those cancers that is kind of what would be called it in-between cancer because technically it's a blood-based cancer
similar to leukemia but it forms solid tumors
So Ivermectin tends to be better for the solid tumor type cancer. So
Ivermectin would I would say would be a possibility for someone with lymphoma